YEAH. GOOD MORNING ALL THE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY
JUNE TWENTY FOURTH IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED
ON AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEED IS BEING MADE
IS ALSO BE TELEVISED. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS
EVENT MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES. ATTENDEES MUST ALSO
REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES. THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES WERE SUBJECTED
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GOING HERE I AM HERE THAT
ENERGY LARA GIVES THEM HEAR ME
YEAH ANYTIME MATHIS YOUR CALL
HAS THERE. YEAH HERE GIVE ME
ONE HERE HOWEVER THERE. ARE WE
HAVE A QUORUM HAVE A CAN CHEN.
IS OUR MOTION THE CONSENT
AGENDA MOVER MISTER GIPSON
SECULAR MEMBERS ARE CUNNINGHAM
THE SECTOR PLEASE. CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY HI. YEAH KAMLAGER
I'M ON THE I'VE LARA GIVES THEM
TIME GIPSON HI B. I THE FIVE
MAJOR AIRLINE MAIENSCHEIN ARE-
THIS TIME ALMOST ALL OF MY
RUBIO HI RUBIO HIRE PEOPLE
RIGHT. LONG LIVE WHERE HI
WHATEVER FIVE. THE MOST OF PASS
I THANK YOU ALL FOR. US SIT
HERE FOR A MOMENT I THINK WE'RE
GOOD OKAY WE'RE WILL ADJOURN
THIS RULE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.